una epidemia que no está fuera de
control pero cuya situación es
preocupante así comenzó la entrevista en
televisión de emanuel alma con el
presidente anunció un toque de queda
tanto para parís como para 8 áreas
metropolitanas que están en alerta
máxima por la pandemia con esto esperan
disminuir el número de contagios que
diariamente alcanzan los 20 mil casos el
toque de queda entrará a regir este
sábado entre las nueve de la noche y las
seis de la mañana por las próximas
cuatro semanas con posibilidad de
ampliar a seis más no habrá
restricciones en el desplazamiento de
las personas ni en el transporte público
de hecho los franceses podrán salir de
vacaciones el presidente además anunció
nuevas medidas económicas para ayudar a
los sectores más impactados por este
toque de queda y pidió a los franceses
que cumplan a cabalidad con las medidas
barreras aún en la esfera privada y que
cuando se reúnen ya sea entre familia o
entre amigos se hacen grupos máximo de
seis personas en el marco aceptó que un
error en su estrategia y de su gobierno
en cuanto a los textos psr que han
saturado en los laboratorios en las
últimas semanas por eso espera ya una
generalización del test de antígeno que
es mucho más rápido que ahora
y hacerse en farmacia y que espera
también haya el desarrollo de un test
incluso que se pueda hacer en sus casas
pidió además dijo que habrá también una
aplicación de rastreo una nueva
aplicación que vendrá a reemplazar la
que se utiliza desde el desde el verano
y que finalmente ha sido un fracaso
presentación de esta aplicación la
próxima semana y por último pues les
dijo a los franceses que espera que de
esto salgamos todos juntos citó pero que
necesita el aporte de cada uno